[Music]  I'm covered in glitter I'm sorry so look  et caught up with chrissy teigen at  thursday night Sports Illustrated  Swimsuit bash just hours after we sat  down with her in New York that's where  she posted this shot naked in our green  room now she's ready to auction off the  et chair for charity thank you  Oh in a heartbeat I would do that in a  heartbeat I'm literally still pulling  this out I'm sorry no of course anything  for charity hello I'll sign army you  should have brought it Chris he also  shared her secret to nailing the perfect  photo pose oh I love to lay on my side  that's my favorite because I'm lazy so I  always I'm the first one to be like  let's do one like this and I lay down on  my side and then I pop my butt and that  makes me I just feel good that way I  love it